PROFESSOR: And so now let's
consider the spreading
of infections, disease indoors.
So the McKendrick-Kermack models
and various compartment models
that we just described start
from the assumption essentially
of a well-mixed
population, where there's
no spatial
dependence, no network
dependence of connectivity
of people with each other
but rather sort of everyone
is interacting with everyone
in some sort of average sense.
So that philosophy
has also been brought
to bear on spreading
events indoors
where a little bit
stronger assumption is made
is that the transmission is
occurring through the air
and the air is well-mixed.
So not only are the people
well-mixed in the sense
that they can interact
with each other regardless
of their distance apart or
anywhere placed in the room,
but the reason it's
a valid approximation
is because the air
itself is well-mixed.
And so we've
already been talking
about the air, the
well-mixed air,
and we've calculated
transmission rate.
Now let's start to connect
that to disease-spreading.
So one concept there
would be to consider
that the initial number
of infected people, i0,
enters a room or an indoor
space with n persons,
including the infectors,
for a time, tau.
So we now have introduced
a finite timescale, which
is the time spent in the room.
So you have a room.
Some people are in it, and we're
imagining an infected person
comes in, and they spend
a certain amount of time,
and then they leave.
And during that time we'd like
to ask ourselves what happened
with all the other people.
How many people were infected?
OK?
So this tau kind of acts like
the inverse of the removal
rate, but we also will
assume that gamma tau is
much less than 1.
So if we think of gamma as the
recovery rate or the death rate
from the disease, so
that's the removal quantity
at the population
level, then we're
assuming the time spent in the
room is small compared to that.
So in other words, while
you're in the room,
nobody is going to be
recovering or dying.
We're just simply going to
be transmitting the disease
for a certain amount of time.
So the r is gone.
On the other hand, we can also
consider an exposed compartment
of the population,
the group in the room.
So the exposed group is
one which has essentially
been exposed to the
pathogen, so let's say
they've inhaled a critical
quantity of the virus,
but they have not yet become
themselves infectious.
So they are already exposed.
They are going to come
down with the disease.
So they are going to be
eventually symptomatic
and potentially infectious, but
they may not be infectious yet.
So the exposed group basically
has received the disease.
So it's been transmitted
to them but is not yet
themselves infectious.
So that's another sort of group
that we want to think about.
So another way to say it,
they're not yet contagious.
So they're going to get sick,
but they're not contagious yet.
So I should put here
contagious is another word you
could think about using.
So we've gotten rid of r,
the recovered compartment,
but we've added e.
So instead of the SEIR
model, we have the SEI model.
Now, where we can write
down the same kinds
of equations as before.
ds dt is minus beta, and
I'll write beta of t,
si, because another
complexity here
is we know is that as soon as
the infected person comes in
if it's airborne
transmission, it takes time
through the fluid
mechanics that we were just
describing for the
concentration to build up.
So the transmission
rate is not constant.
We've actually
already calculated
that transmission rate, but
it now enters this equation.
So this is now the susceptible
people are getting exposed.
And so when that sort of
reaction happens, if you will,
the exposed
population then grows,
and then there's a
certain rate with which
exposed people can become
themselves infectious
to others.
And that rate we'll call alpha.
So we can remove exposed
people at a rate alpha,
and when they're removed
they become infected people.
And so then the number
of infections grows.
So this is a very
closely-related model
that we could solve.
And in order to couple this
to airborne disease-spreading,
we need to go back to our
model of the airborne pathogen.
So, for example, the virions per
air volume which we called c,
and, in fact, I'll even
write this as a dc dt
with a partial derivative,
which is p, which depends
on the size, r, divided by--
actually this should be v--
minus lambda c of
rc, so that was
the model we just talked
about, which we have to solve.
And then the beta of t
is the breathing rate
times the integral over all
these sizes of c of r and t
and then ci, and of
course there could
be masks, which might also
be size dependent, dr.
So we tie it together this way.
This kind of model,
which is typically
run without accounting
for the size dependents,
but that has been done
by some authors as well,
generally falls under the
category of Wells-Riley models.
And I mentioned here
that Wells actually
was a real pioneer here,
already starting in the 1930s.
Did careful studies of
disease transmission,
including for flu and
other viral diseases,
and really was one of
the initial proponents
of the idea of infectious
air, that there are particles
suspended in the air which
can become infectious.
He also was the
one who pioneered
the Wells curve, which explored
evaporation versus settling.
And in 1955, he introduced
this kind of a model
where he was taking into account
the balance of the production
rate, p, and then the
ventilation rate in order
to describe the buildup of the
infectious droplets in the air.
And then the transmission is
connected in this way here.
And I should say that
in Wells-Riley modeling,
usually e is ignored,
and so we normally just
go straight from s to i.
So I'll say e is neglected,
and what that really
means is that the incubation
rate here, this alpha,
is the incubation rate.
So it's the rate at which
an exposed person becomes
infectious or contagious.
That alpha t is
much less than 1.
So it's essentially
the Wells-Riley model,
it's the slow incubation limit.
But we've written down
something more general here,
which does also allow for
the possibility of exposed
people that have not yet--
that could become infectious,
so we'll come back
to that in just a moment.
So let's kind of
summarize the results
of the Wells-Riley approach.
So we'll consider the slow
incubation limit, which
is alpha tau much less than 1.
And so in that case, if
there's slow incubation,
during the time of the infected
person being in the room,
there is no time for new
people to become infectious.
So it's really just
like a fixed source.
So it's essentially
saying that i
is equal to i0,
which is a constant.
So even though the disease
is being transmitted,
there is no kind of
amplification effect
because the people
who have been exposed
are not able to
themselves infect others
because the incubation
is too slow.
And this model
here, where you sort
of couple these equations with
the si equations basically,
that was done by Gammaitoni
and Nucci in 1997.
So you can see
starting from Wells,
we start to move towards this
picture of actually coupling
the dynamics of the pathogen
to the transmission.
And there have been a
number of models since then
which have even taken
into account some
of these aspects of
the different drop
sizes and other
effects that we've
been discussing that were not
initially considered by Wells.
So that's this.
So the first thing to do
is to deal with beta of t.
So how are we going to do that?
So if I put beta t
on the other side
here, if I kind
of divide it down,
you can see that I
really would like
to define a new differential
of a variable t hat, which
is beta of t times dt.
That would be my definition
of a new variable.
And so when i integrate
this, it tells me
that I should really
switch to a new time
variable, which is
not just t, but it's
the integral of beta dt.
So it's a time-like variable.
And once I do that I'm
essentially sweeping this guy
into the derivative there.
And if I also assume that
i is roughly equal to i0,
then what I have now is a
much simpler equation here.
I go from this
non-linear equation
with time-dependent
coefficients to something
which is now linear.
And we have ds dt hat is
approximately equal to beta--
sorry-- which is minus i0s.
So, again, our i is
roughly constant.
Our beta got swept
into the time.
So this is just kind of a
simple exponential relaxation.
And the initial value is that s
at time equals 0 is n minus i0.
So there are n people.
i0 of them are the
initial infected ones.
And so this a pretty
easy equation to solve.
It's just an exponential
relaxation, which we've already
seen a few times before.
And so the solution
is that s is n
minus i0, the
initial value of s,
times e to the minus i0t hat.
So it's i0, integral
0 to t of beta dt.
And then we can also write--
so that's the s,
and the e is just
if we have fast incubation--
or sorry, slow incubation,
this term is gone,
and we basically just
have e as sort of just--
s and e have to add
up to n basically.
And so we're left with e of t
is n minus i and then 1 minus,
and let me actually write
this quantity up here
as little q of t, where
little q of t is i0 times
the time integral of beta dt.
And what is this q here?
This q can be thought of as
the number of infection quanta
per time that are
released by the infectors
because their i's are infectors.
Each one of them is infecting
another individual person
at a rate beta, and that
beta is time-dependent,
so you have to
integrate in time.
And so this is telling
me the total number
of people that would be infected
by those infected people
if you weren't running
into all of the limits that
are described by this model.
So what is happening is that
if someone gets exposed,
they can't be exposed
again, so there's
some numbers there
that are changing,
so you can't keep passing an
infection quantum to somebody
and have them get
infected over and over.
So that doesn't happen.
But what this is measuring is
somehow the number of times
that somehow there's
been an attempted
infection or an
expected infection
if a person were susceptible.
So this q of t here is
the infection quanta
as defined by Wells
transmitted in time t.
So up to time t, there
are i0 infectors--
that number's not
changing-- and the way
you can think about this
kind of airborne transmission
is they're essentially
spewing out infection quanta.
Each one of them if it hits a
potentially susceptible person
will infect them, but the
number of susceptible people
is changing.
So it's not like you keep
getting more infections.
Eventually you
run out of people,
and you can't keep
infecting them,
but that's one way
to think about this.
And we've already
calculated this concept
of infection quanta in the
context of the breathing.
We've defined a
quantity, which is
the number of infection quanta
per volume of exhaled breath.
We've also talked about
the quanta emission
rates for people and connected
that back to the droplets.
And so here's how you see
how that quantity enters
into the
disease-spreading models.
And in fact, we can sketch
what happens with s and i here.
So basically if we start
with s, for example, starts
at the value n minus i0 and
as you go in time it decays--
well, the decay
rate is basically
set by sort of the average beta.
So this is kind of
like some kind of maybe
if you're getting
close to steady state,
then beta inverse is sort
of what this timescale is.
But what's actually
happening is you cut it off
at a certain time, tau.
So that's the time that
you're in the room.
In that time, the number
of susceptible people
has gone down, and the number
of exposed people goes up.
But then because the
incubation rate is slow,
the exposed people never become
infectious in this model.
So the number of
infectors is fixed.
And so since we
have slow incubation
and since the number
of infectors is fixed,
another way to look
at this is notice
this non-linear equation,
which had s times i,
it became i0 times s.
So it became a linear response.
And so another way to
think about this limit
is this is the limit
of linear response.
So the Wells-Riley
models are basically
linear response models,
which are typically
not taking into account a growth
in the number of infectors,
which would lead to
kind of an amplification
of disease-spreading in a room.
And that's often justified
because the time someone
spends in a room is often times
a lot less than the incubation
time, which could be
on the order of days.
People might only spend
a few hours in the room.
On the other hand, there are
situations such as classrooms,
long-term care facilities and
homes, prisons, workplaces,
where people are exposed
to each other for days
or weeks or months actually.
They may go home in between,
but there's a constant exposure.
And so you may need to worry
about these other sorts
of dynamics, even in an
indoor setting actually.
So we'll come back to that.
Now another important
concept I'd like to get here
is what is the early
rate of infection.
So this quantity here is q.
I wrote n minus 1 here.
That was the case.
Actually more
generally this should
be n minus i0 because
often times we're
thinking of one infector,
so I kind of jumped to that,
but more generally
it'd be n minus i0,
And this quantity
here is also s0.
That's the initial number
of susceptible people.
So basically you take the
initial number of susceptible,
and they slowly
become exposed based
on how many quanta
they've consumed.
Now, the definition
of quanta of infection
often is tied to this equation.
This essentially is the Wells
equation, derived in 1955.
And Wells actually
defined quanta from this.
He said that one quantum
infection corresponds
to a probability of
transmission of 63%
because if you put q
equals minus 1, 1 minus e
to the minus 1 is 63%.
So basically he said a quantum--
so if someone asks you what
is a quantum infection--
a quantum is basically
63% chance of infection.
But the problem
with that thinking
though is that in some other
situation where there is maybe
incubation going on, I might
get more infected people.
So I can't just count the
infected people in a room
and assume that I'm getting a
measure of infection quanta.
Infection quanta actually
are defined by beta.
That's an important thing.
So really what is beta?
It's actually the rate of
infection quantum transfer
from infectious to susceptible.
Sorry.
It's si basically.
Oh actually did I--
no, that's correct, yeah.
So it's the rate of
basically becoming exposed.
Excuse me.
So it's from
susceptible to exposed.
So that rate basically
defines beta,
and that is giving you the rate
of infection quanta transfer.
How many people actually
get infected or exposed
involves solving
some set of equations
like this, which
might not be the same
as the Wells-Riley model.
So that's an important
thing to keep in mind,
and we'll come back to that.
So this is basically Wells'
definition of a quantum
is that basically there's
a 63% chance that it's
going to infect
somebody, but that's
completely tied to this
linear response exponential
relaxation.
It's not really, I don't think,
is the appropriate definition.
Now, another thing we can ask
is, what about at early times.
And that would be the case where
the expected number of quanta
transferred is less than 1.
So at early times you haven't
really seen a lot of infection
take place.
This will be very
important for us
because we're going to
come to safety guidelines,
and in my opinion the right
way to think about a safety
guideline is you don't
want one person to cause
one or more infections.
You'd like the expectation to be
that less than one person will
get infected.
So this, what I'm
calling early times here,
in the epidemiological
model is actually
very relevant for,
like, safety guidelines.
You don't want to
deal with the case
where there's rampant infection.
You just want to say if
an infected person comes
in the room, are they going
to infect anybody else.
And you want that to
be a low probability.
So this is a very
relevant limit.
Now, if I take that limit here,
I can expand this exponential,
and I find that e
of t at early times
behaves like s0
times q of t if s0
is the number of susceptibles.
And if I plug in
what we have here,
that's n minus i0 times i0 times
the integral in time of beta.
And so this is the
expected number
of people that will be
infected by i0 infected people.
So the ratio of these two
things is very important.
So if I look at e in time tau.
I should say we do this
integral-- typically
we want to go up to dd which is
the time that the person spends
in the room, and we divide
by the initial number,
then that's basically
telling us sort
of what's the reproductive
number of the room.
i0 people come in,
and the question
is do more than i0 people
come out that are infected.
So have you infected others?
So that's the ratio that
you really care about.
And so I would call this the
indoor reproductive number.
And in this case, if
we pick i0 equal to 1,
then this is n minus
1, 0 to tau beta dt.
So that's going to be an
important thing, which we'll
come back to later, which is
the definition of kind of what
makes a room actually safe.
Well, what we'd like to do
is have this quantity be
much less than 1 because I want
to say if one infector comes
in the room and
everybody is currently
susceptible and healthy,
I want to make sure
that less than one person
actually gets infected
And there'll be
some tolerance maybe
on how low I'd like
that to be, but that's
a very important concept.
And here you see it comes out
of the slow incubation limit.
What I'd like to
show you next is
that the very same indoor
reproductive number actually
occurs for any model
including the opposite limit
of fast incubation.